To figure out what was happening in the last question, let's just look at one
of those numbers as an example to explore more. How about that first one? 3.1
times 10 to the 4th. We can keep 3.1 as is, but we know that 10 to the 4th can
be written differently. This is just 10,000. So, 3.1 times 10 to the 4th is
equal to 3.1 times 10,000. What do we do now? Well, you may remember that to
multiply a number by 10, you add a 0. But in reality, what you're actually
doing is moving the decimal point of the number one place to the right when you
multiply by 10. And in some cases, this requires the addition of a 0. For
example, if we look at the number 31 and we want to multiply it by 10, we need
to note that the decimal point is invisible, but it's technically right here.
We need to move it from being right after the 1, the one place to the right.
And since there's nothing here right now, we need to add a 0 in, then we put a
decimal point after that 0. In this case though, we're dealing with 10 to the
4th power, so what do we do in that situation? Well, for each 10 that's here,
this number is going to get ten times bigger, so the decimal needs to move one
step to the right in each of those factors of 10. The first time we move it, we
end up with 31. The next time we move it, the decimal point would be out here,
and here we have one of those invisible spaces. We know we're going to need to
put a 0 there, but let's not derail ourselves at this point. We've already
moved over two times, so that takes care of two of our four factors of 10. We
need two more. There's our third and there is our fourth. So our decimal point
started out right here. And in the end, it's all the way out here to the right.
We went from having 3.1, to having 31, to having 310, to 3,100, and finally, to
31,000. This is where our decimal point would belong if we decided to write it
in. We know it's generally invisible though, for numbers that don't have
decimals written outside of them. To give you a chance to try out what we've
been talking about, see if you can write out that number that we had at the end
of the last question. 3.1 times 10 to the 21. How would you write this using
our normal number notation, not scientific?